you will present as some of his
experience in deploying differential
lights alright thanks for coming out
here and actually I'm going to thank the
audience this time
thanks thanks all of you for
participating in this workshop and
making it a success
my name is Ashwin my last name is
Martino viola if you don't take my
course you don't need to know how to
spell it
alright I'm going to talk about some of
my experiences in deploying differential
privacy in sort of mostly in Statistical
agencies are in collaboration with
statisticians and social scientists a
lot of two very ambitious goals for this
talk which I probably will fall short of
and the two goals really are for
practitioners in the audience sort of
highlight what are the important steps
and deployment of differential privacy
in statistical agencies and in other
agencies as well
and maybe sort of mention some of the
tools that they can use we've heard a
lot about the tools that people can use
that ever reason both on the statistic
community and this is community in the
last few days and we will hear more
today and tomorrow as well but I just
want to sort of that that's one I won
one gold and the other goal is basically
for for the privacy researchers in the
audience what are some sort of open
questions and CS and stats which which
sort of arise when you actually start
deploying differential privacy and maybe
I feel like some of these problems we've
not really thought too much about or we
have thought about them but they still
got a lot of sort of open problems okay
and the goal of this talk should be is
to be interactive if you want me to
please please stop me with questions I
don't need to sort of finish everything
that I have okay all right I'm going to
start with this this is what I call is a
checklist for deployment which which
sort of typically is what what what you
need to do when you're going around and
trying to deploy differential privacy
which is basically to start off like
before you even think about privacy or
anything you need to really know what
your data is right know what your data
is don't try to force fit it into a
single table but basically understand
what are the what are the what the
entities in your data is data or to the
relationships and also more importantly
sort of formulate its uses where are the
data being used for right what are its
uses what do people care about I think
it's a very very important task before
you even go into the process of you know
deploying differential differential
privacy right and then once you know
what your data is I'm going to talk a
little bit about what do you mean what I
mean by designing your privacy model
right differential privacy
the original definition at least sort of
things things in terms of a single table
when your data is a little more complex
you may need to think a little bit about
how you sort of set up your differential
privacy for the problem I'm going to
talk a little bit about that and and
then then once you set up your privacy
model then you can sort of start
thinking about designing algorithms and
we've heard a lot of talks about how you
design algorithms for differential
privacy and finally and this this came
up I'm very happy it came up a lot today
in today's talk is really understand how
do you develop methods to sort of
estimate error in the release data
communicate the error in the release
data and take that into account in your
downstream Tran stream analysis right
and so today's talking we sort of talked
a little bit about these three aspects
are designing your privacy model I'll
mention some work update with the US
Census Bureau some of you may have heard
off about it already then I talked a
little bit about designing a
differential algorithm and and I talked
about some of the questions that that
are still open technically or open in
the space and and finally I'll talk a
little bit about developing methods to
sort of estimate error and in particular
about your privately verifying error in
mechanisms all right so for the first
part the sort of the running example
would use is this is this product that
the US Census Bureau released is called
on the map several of you might have
heard about it but basically it's it's a
product where data is collected from
service and also administrative data and
they are and they're linked
and these data then then published on
this sort of on this interactive website
which allows you to learn where people
work where people live what their jobs
are the salaries are they what is
starting and ending dates of their jobs
are and so on okay so here is an example
visualizations from from this from this
product and there's a and there's
several interesting uses for this data
set one kind of use case is basically
for resource allocations in certain
kinds of situations so one situation one
one use case and one the map has been
for emergency management so when you
have like hurricane or a snowstorm right
so several individuals are no longer
able to either go to their jobs or they
are affected and so there is a process
where you have to sort of determine
whether a certain region in in the US is
there a county or a civil division Civil
Division has to qualifies for support
from from the government right and so
therefore you need to sort of tabulate
how many how many people and of what
categories are affected by that by that
emergency right and this is one of the
use cases where these data are used
because it sort of tabulates up how many
jobs were affected by a certain there's
a certain thing like in this case is no
snow meeting all right so that's the use
so what does the data look like for this
one the data looks like this so
basically it's a it's a those of you who
don't know what this is this is like a
entity relationship diagram which is
typical when you store data in
relational databases you have three
kinds of entities here you have
employees which are people your
employers which are businesses and you
have jobs and so each in this according
to this each employee has a job and each
employer in particular in the primary
job and each employer can have multiple
jobs each employer can be each employer
can imply many many employees and then
there are attributes associated with
each of these kinds of
kinds of entities and the goal here is
to sort of release this tab tabular
summaries so you want to release sort of
things like counting queries so how do
you count jobs of jobs held by workers
of aged 30 who work in the city of
Boston marginal queries of the form
counts of jobs held by workers of aged
thirty across different work locations
and so on right so the goal is this and
but the goal here was to release
statistics that can allow you to run
tabulate these kinds answer these kinds
of counting queries and tabulate these
kinds of marginals in such a way that it
sort of preserve privacy right so so in
this piece of world rather than sort of
directly saying okay we're going to use
something use something a differential
policy we said okay let's look at what
the privacy requirements are okay
so what are the privacy requirements
here the private is recommend for for
the US Census Bureau comes comes from
title 13 section nine and here it
basically says essentially that the
whatever data is being published by the
US Census Bureau should be in such a way
that it doesn't identify particular
establishments and particularly
individuals so not only it should should
do not should we think about the privacy
of individuals you already think about
in privacy of establishments as well so
here's an example where you have to
think about tribes you have multiple
entities that are there in this right
and of course it comes with like heavy
heavy fines here for every violation so
remember for every record that you sort
of harm you this is the kind of value
fines that are applied here okay so of
course it is very succinct there's
nothing really you can it's very hard to
be in something completely out of this
right and so what we did in this
scenario was was we actually looked at
what the current interpretation of the
law was and this law is being this law
has been interpreted by the US Census
Bureau in particular by disclosure IV
bolts for for several decades and so
based on that interpretations we were
able to have glean of privacy
requirement so so in particular we go
three sort of privacy requirements one
is basically that the existence of a job
held by a particular individual must not
be disclosed right and sort of inverts
that sort of make more sense to us it
was sort of like you don't want to you
want don't want any exactly
identification of employee records by
some sort of an informed attacker yes
you don't want to know that there's a
gender you don't want to know that
there's a janitor his name by a
particular individual existence of a job
held by a particular individual by a
particular individual so you should not
know that this individual held the job
of a janitor in this company right so
that's that's there and it doesn't say
anything about time so it could have
held it a read upon a time edition I'd
be able to tell that alone II was a
graduate student at the at MIT
at least that's a interpretation the
other interpretation basically was that
the existence of an employer business in
almost most cases as well as this type
or sector and location is not
confidential these that physical
businesses are actually physically exist
in some physical location because if you
look at the schema before there was an
address or a geography associated with
that that thing and since these are
businesses physical locations presumably
you can go and check that it exists so
the existence of this is not find
potential you don't decide the presence
or absence of an employer but the data
on the operations of this particular
business must be protected
and this is basically the kind of
interpretation that they had was sort of
different from what we usually think of
what the interpretation could have been
but essentially the the interpretation
was that there is some sort of aggregate
properties of this business like like
for example the number of employers and
I'm Griffin price of a certain type and
so on and so you don't need like perfect
secrecy of off of that you don't need to
perfectly hide how many employers the
employees are there in that employer
because again if you know what the
business is then you probably know
roughly it's a big business or a small
business but rather what you want to do
is you want to basically have sufficient
uncertainty about about the size of that
business in particular the uncertainty
of up to some sort of multiplicative
factor of this on the workforce of an
employee and so so what do you want to
sort of sort of talk about here is
really whatever the stress on here is
there is that it's good to know what is
the basis for privacy in an application
because that sort of gives you some sort
of starting point to think about how
what is the appropriate privacy for for
an application so in this case we got
this and then we said okay let's take
this and run with these and that that's
that's what we are trying to sort of
protect okay so this is differential
privacy there's a definite different
policy I'm just going to define it just
because it's a different privacy talk
that essentially what differentiate or I
see the differences is that for for
every pair of neighboring tables that
that our algorithm operates on that
differ in one row in the presence or
absence of one row and in this case this
red row is missing and for every
possible output this mechanism can
generate in this case so your attack
that should not be able to distinguish
based on this over whether it came from
d1 or d2 and mathematically its form
later does the log of this this sort of
odds ratio is bounded by Epsilon right
now now in our setting what do these
neighboring tables but what should
neighboring tables look like all right
because we have multiple things that we
have multiple you don't have a single
table anymore multiple tables any
databases there's three linked tables
now right and in which ways should these
one set of three linked tables be
neighboring to another set of Freleng
tables right there's a based on the
constraints here we could naturally come
up with something right so in this case
maybe the neighboring databases could be
of the form that in one case one
employee works at uber and other
employee works for Microsoft or in
another kind of Raving this is like one
employee works at Microsoft another
employee in the other case the employer
is employee is just unemployed or
another way like in one case when
employers say uber has a thousand
employees in another case it has
thousand and fifty employees alpha is
five percent and so on right so you can
set up this you have privacy like that
and then you can check differential
privacy all right now the question is
why why is this why does this law match
this this kind of a definition right so
so when you in your definition is sort
of - it has very nice semantic
interpretations in terms of the fact
that anything in adversity can any-any
in front adversity with some sort of
prior over databases right whatever they
learn here they can learn in in the case
where one of the one of the data records
in the database has been removed or one
of the database records in the database
has been added right you can get nice
semantic interpretations when you have
sort of this kind of neighboring
databases or another variant of
differential privacy what does the
semantics look like and so we need some
sort of understanding of that so one way
to sort of get that kind of understand
is using the the what we call the
pufferfish framework it sort of things
about price is slightly differently but
it allows you to be a little more
flexible right and then but basically
what we can say is rather than talking
about neighboring tables we can talk
about what is being kept secret so this
is determined as a set of pairs of
statements over over over a database or
order domain and these are sort of
mutually exclusive pairs of Secrets of
the farm like in one case Bob works for
uber another case Bob is unemployed when
one case uber has a thousand employees
and another case uber thousand fifty
employees and so on and and and
basically the goal is to sort of make
sure that a certain set of chosen
adversaries can't distinguish between
them
so these are sort of sets of date what
we think of as data evaluation so the
way data was generated you can also
think of adversarial priors and the goal
is to make make sure that for every
adversary and for every pair of the
discriminative secrets the posterior
odds of of one secret were enough versus
another secret after you see the output
of your algorithm should be close to the
prior odds of the the ratio of this of
these secrets okay I'm not going to go
into detail about like the theory behind
it but basically the advantages of this
is essentially the privacy is defined
more generally in terms of customisable
secrets or than records and now your
pricey definition can take into account
things that you are releasing like for
example in relational database your
constraints between tables foreign key
which means that if you remove and if
employee employer record is removed and
all of the employees in that should be
which would be remove from the jobs
table so you can have those kinds of
constraints and we can sort of tailor
the set of discriminative secret parents
to things that we really sort of care
about right and so in this in this word
basically what we did was basically we
were able to take this loss and
mathematically write out these privacy
requirements in terms of sets of
adversaries and pairs of Secrets and
ensure that the neighboring definitions
that we came up with actually imply
those and then design algorithms to
satisfy that
okay question
so what you just said was you took the
law you expressed it in terms of puffer
fish you show that DP implies the
purposes it implies it's efficient yeah
presumably what you would want to do is
if you really think that the puffer fish
is equivalent to the law and since
puffer fish is probably easier than DP
you want to have algorithms that only
give you puffer fish yeah come back yeah
that's a hard problem the question is
what was gained no no what do you mean
what was gained no okay let me say one
thing let me say one thing so the the
the gain that you get here basically is
like it's not it's not directly
differential privacy right the
definition here we have is like some
weird combinations of weird combinations
of neighboring databases like you can
come up with whatever combination of
interfaces you want right like for
example if I have a location stream or
your sensor data right
I could say I'm going to protect privacy
where neighboring databases are your
location at some second or at some nano
second is that a good notion of privacy
probably not right and the reason that
probably not is basically where this the
semantics will tell you that if you do
it that way then essentially the only
kinds of Secrets you can't distinguish
is your location and on a second but if
I you even interested in your location
over this period of time you will not
get any kind of guarantees right and
that's that's the reason why that's what
this gives us that's the gain you get
make sense yes you say you worried about
how do you think about matching the
prior the adversary for the data
evolutionary yes with the law or all
right I was hoping not to get into it
but since you raised it I guess I have
to all right okay so this is the subtle
this is the subtleness about defining
defining privacy right and there are two
ways in which you can you can define the
semantics of privacy definitions right
so one way is to think about in terms of
your
versus who have some priors you're
looking at what is the push the
likelihood of off what is the likelihood
of of the posterior likelihood of some
property given the output right whereas
what is the probability or some other
property given the given the output
right and in if you want this kind of a
privacy guarantee they're always sort of
arbitrarily bad priors under which you
can get no kinds of bumps right the
other way of doing it so therefore you
have to necessarily make some kinds of
assumptions on on these priors in this
particular scenario the kinds of
assumptions we made were basically that
in this in this case audio kind of
assumptions we may do basically like the
the attacker doesn't know correlations
between different employers and their
workforces but but and then conditioned
on where an employee is working then
there are no correlation between
employees you sort of have to
necessarily make those kinds of
assumptions the other kind of semantics
that you can think of are the simulation
semantics and so for the simulation
semantics the way it works is basically
you have a attacker who has some
knowledge of the data generating
distribution of the of the data set you
draw a data set from that right and you
look at the posterior likelihood of some
property and you compare it to another
scenario where you draw the data set but
then you take this actual sample of the
data that you've gotten and you act on
it and remove a record okay this is
different from drawing the probability
of drawing a database where that record
doesn't exist right
in fact the database where you acted
upon it and remove that record may not
even be possible from the distribution
that you're drawn the data set from
right but under that kind of
assimilation semantics you can show it
doesn't matter no matter what the prior
is this sort of ratio can be can be
bounded right so these are two different
ways of sort of thinking about privacy
and it'll be nice to have a way to marry
them because in this semantics you can
think more generally about sets of sort
of discriminative perish and so on and
the simulation semantics unfortunately
are at least at least for me this is how
you model these sort of secrets very
heavily depends on these modification
strategies like what kind of actions can
you do on the database right and it's I
think somewhere needs to be done or
understanding what is the right set of
modification strategies that can match
with the notion of keeping something
secret that is one the second
complication comes in when you when your
data evolution scenarios may set may
need to incorporate exact constraints in
the data so if you go back to Monday's
talk about how the census has to release
data and in addition release exact
invariants right so again you can do two
kinds of analyses here in the simulation
the simulation space right in the
simulation is one kind of argument you
can basically make is essentially that I
am acting on the database without
looking at the invariance at all right
not only in the database not be possible
to be generated in the description it
may not even be matching the invariants
right then the kind of guarantee you
will get is like yes I can bound my sort
of disclosure but essentially you're
saying it's not the fault of the
differential privacy algorithm but you
could get sort of leakage through the
likud disclosure through the invariants
right but if I am sort of Census Bureau
and I am releasing both of this I want
to really know what is my overall
privacy loss and then like you have to
really be careful about thinking about
under which modification strategies can
it make any bounds and this is a very
very tricky problem and this is
something that we are sort of thinking
about and I think that needs to be more
work here and yes so we can discuss this
offline
- comments or questions one is the
existence of these the environment seems
to already destroy the assumption of
Independence but you can you yeah if you
have invariance and you will basically
condition like if you use the power of
semantics you would be something like
independent conditioned on the
invariance or something like that right
so you you will say that you have an
invariant you basically that is true and
then every database that you generate it
will have that invariant this is not
every definition and Delta power which
will not come oh yeah every definition
under profit does not compose there
exists largely size of it which compose
but again as I said every set of a fish
definition does not does not mean it's a
good definition but that's as follows on
the fact that I could construct a bad
set of neighboring data set therefore
and give an explanation for it so this
is a good way to think about explaining
what your privacy notion is and then you
can decide is it a good explanation this
is it is it a good definition or not
right if the set of adversaries you try
you can protect against is really small
it's probably a bad definition right if
the kinds of further for the secrets you
care about if the bounds you get are
very bad then again it's a bad
definition it does often it does not
tell you that every definition is
generate from here is good it just gives
you an explanation for the definition
I'm going to move on at this point I
will take more questions in the break
okay Marco how much time all right so
the other important point I want to
raise here was we did something that a
lot of people do not do which is think
about utility cost and I think we need
more papers that think about what this
kind of a utility cost so what do you
mean but it will be cost here so in this
case that already existed a mechanism
for releasing the data right based on
existing SDL technology and
we are proposing a new algorithm that
has some sort of formal privacy
guarantees and so now you want to ask
not not only whether the mechanism the
degenerate has good accuracy properties
but also in comparison to the previous
SDL techniques which obviously also has
some error guarantees like how does it
compare right and in some sense you are
getting more now because your pricey
guarantee gives you a transparency it
gives you provable guarantees and so on
so you want to sort of see what are you
losing in terms of accuracy or utility
for the gain in terms of the privacy
properties and you have not too much
time I'm just going to say that in a lot
of settings that we the settings of
epsilon and since you have to an TDC of
two different privacy laws parameters
one for employees and employ employers
for various different settings and
across different algorithms we could we
could actually find lots of cases where
we had lesser error then the existing
STL is DL technique for the the tasks of
releasing sort of Louis reasonable
dimension marginals but then and in some
cases we were only up to three times
worse so I think this was a this is a
interesting recipe says that there are
cases where you can actually do as well
as DL techniques it's not like
differential privacy or formal privacy
technology will lead to a loss in
accuracy compared to a steer and this is
something that has to sort of sink in we
should do more of these experiments you
should show more of these comparisons
because I think for a large number of
tasks are differentiated techniques I do
do very well ok yeah so different lines
are basically there are two kinds of
parameters here one parameter
corresponding to the people person
another parameter corresponding to the
the employer so essentially different
lines correspond to the x axis curve for
the privacy of the individual and the
line here the these points correspond to
the privacy of the employer and so when
you have as alpha increases you get more
privacy for the employer at the same
cost same level of privacy for the
individual
all right so the pickle is here
basically there are a lot class of tasks
for which you can accurately there can
be accurately performed using you know
differential I co variant or
differential privacy and in some cases
more accurately than STL techniques and
we definitely need more such empirical
comparisons in such evidence in the
literature so that you know you can you
can show that this is doable the other
thing is basically I think and this may
be a little controversial obviously a
careful analysis of privacy requirements
can help design mechanisms better
privacy utility trade-offs right I want
to point out that real data is rarely
flat right real data is very relational
right here is the somebody mentioned
mimic yesterday which is like like a EHR
data set right it has what 643 tables
and 63 relationships between these
tables it's super complex right and you
have entities of all kinds of touchy of
people entities there are patients
admissions of patients you have lab
entities or caregivers you have all
kinds of sort of entities and now
thinking about whose privacy do you want
occur it is an interesting question do
you want to kinda price you the of the
patient or the entire patient sector you
don't to guarantee privacy at the level
of an admissions of a patient do you
want to get any privacy of calculation
it may be very important that a
caregiver should it should not be leaked
as a caregiver is for example giving
care for Tom Cruise and because they may
be hounded by the paparazzi right and so
it's important to sort of think about at
what level you want to guarantee privacy
and based on the application your prior
to get the where what you choose to
associate privacy is with this Duke
could be different
and now neighboring databases are going
to be more than just sort of adding or
removing a row from say one of these
tips they're open questions here I'm
going to sort of basically say that this
this discussion we had a long discussion
variant and semantically that's that's
very hard there also cases where it's a
little tricky to think about what the
privacy object is like if you have
thermal data or a caustic data right
is no discrete record for an individual
so what does it mean to think about the
effect of an individual on something
right and that may be cases where the
presence of an individual can be
determined by fusing information from
multiple sources we're talking about IOT
space yesterday like no single sensor
may tell you that
Salil was here in this room but by
combining all of the different sensors I
can sort of basically tell that Sally
was in the room right and like I went
into Honeywell and they told me we don't
have personal data okay and they said
yeah we have we track basically for
every lightbulb the timestamp when it
was on that timestamp when it was off I
said ok what kind of bulb do you have
it's a smart bulb right so it turns on
and a person moves next to it and it
turns off as a person moves away and at
night if there's only one person you can
actually track where that person went
all right so so there are there are
cases are it's a little tricky to even
think about what privacy whose privacy
and and so I think it's important to
sort of think carefully about these
problems when when you're deploying to
ensure privacy all right so now I want
to talk a little bit design differential
privacy algorithms but I think you had a
lot of talks about designing
differential privacy algorithm so I'm
going to actually gonna skip this part
of the talk if I know how to do it and
I'm going to talk about third part
yes it went there good all right
talking about estimates of error so
let's say you have a data set you know
it's a it's a distribution of tweets in
some region in the US that's a real data
set and let's say somebody wants to
analyze this and they the curator who is
analyzing this said okay I'm going to
use differential privacy I'm going to
run a differential private algorithm and
release a synopsis that looks like this
that analysts can use so they're on the
differentiy prior algorithm this is the
output you get from this algorithm right
it's a real algorithm it's a real
epsilon reasonable epsilon you can go
and the DP comp website and figure out
what it is and now an analyst comes
along he looks at this data set he
starts analyzing it and it says yeah I
found a new result my null hypothesis
was the distribution of peach should be
identical to the population density this
data does not match the null hypothesis
therefore I have a new result
let's write a paper what's wrong with
this compensate for the noise okay but
something else is going on here it was
related to the the the it's basically
the reason this data looks like this in
fact we showed I think this is the
precise thing that somebody is some sort
of somebody looked at this precise
visualization is like wow you have so
much uniformity have going on everywhere
here the uniformity is not coming from
the data it's a it's an artifact of the
algorithm right the algorithm creates
these boxes all right and then sort of
uniformly spreads the data out there
it's not that it's not coming in the
original data itself right and so the
real question here is how can we
distinguish between artifacts of you
know privacy algorithms and artifacts
arising from the data and before people
pounced on me artifacts in data can
arise from many many sources the
artifact maybe then the data itself
right but it could am missing data
record linkage selection by a sampling
these are very well studied is huge
literature on all of this but they can
also come from Paris mechanisms and we
need more work here and I was happy to
see some people talk about this today
right but you need a lot more work in
this space and we didn't mean more than
six papers in the starts jenny was
talking about this because it starts
guys it really the guys who we know how
to do this stuff right so so this I
think is a very important area that that
we should not ignore right how do we
take into account error but also how do
we take into account biases that can be
introduced because the algorithm has is
make certain decisions right if you know
the algorithm in some cases when you
know the algorithm you can sort of tell
what the biases right if the algorithm
says I am going to assume independent
between these columns
you know what that biases but that
algorithm was basically doing something
complex like doing some complex
optimization and gave you that right
it's sort of a it sort of black box
algorithm it's hard to know that it
created those kinds of things like a
priori just looking at the algorithms
okay so in the last of a few minutes
that I have I want to talk about sort of
one use case of where we found that we
needed to do this we were working with
social scientists at Duke who had access
to data from the Office of Personnel
Management and there was decided stored
in this was a secure server and then the
question we were asked they were asking
us like okay you guys talked about you
know synthetic data like what would
happen if you wanted to do an analysis
on a synthetic data set right so they
wanted to analyze wage gap between
gender and race wage gap in the day
across sort of careers of civil servants
and basically you're asking if we did
the analysis on area on a synthetic way
and I said what would it look like like
and so nobody care with the degree
regression till now so I'm going to talk
about linear regression so this is the
standard tool that they use so in
irrigation is very simple you have a
bunch of explanatory variables you are
not come variable and then you have some
coefficients and you model it this way
and and clearly you can't get a perfect
fit always so your goal is to sort of
find something that has low error and
this error is sometimes called the
residual right
so what do people do with the real data
so here's what they do with the real
data they take it to database they build
a regression model and they check you
know whether this regression model makes
sense
so they are some sort of Diagnostics
here right so what does this diagnostic
telling the diagram is telling them I
mean even having the right fit with this
model like sometimes they are asking for
how much prediction accuracy I have the
prediction error but more importantly
they ask things about model fit right is
this is this linear model even the right
right model for my for my data set right
and one way you can mark you can
identify that is using what is known as
plots of residuals right if you are if
your model is right your residuals
should should be roughly you know
normally distributed right that's that's
the correct assumption and if it is not
then you will see sort of weird patterns
here if it's a non linear you will see
the residues form a nonlinear plot if
your variance is increasing depends on X
you see some sort of a heteroskedastic
and you can sort of detect these from
just the residual exactly exactly thanks
for clarifying yeah okay so how would
you do it on synthetic data well you
have two database you get a database out
out of the firewall and you're looking
at it and then you run your regression
model and then now what are you going to
do regression Diagnostics on this well
it may be that if you did that on the
true data it might confidently tell us
if the relationship is not linear but in
the synthetic we had I said might
confident it unless is the relationship
is linear because maybe the model you
use to generate a synthetic data set was
actually linear right so how do you have
to break this like there is nothing you
can do at the synthetic data level
unless you know very very exhaustively
what this process is to be able to sort
of detect that
is actually what the truth is right and
so so one way you can solve it is to
basically say I will do the regression
Diagnostics I will take this model and I
will check whatever model upness or
model fit with the true database right I
will measure that but of course that has
to be done privately so you need sort of
methods for the spending some want to
your privacy but yet to do this kind of
a verification right and so so we
designed some sort of simple recognition
Diagnostics one for sort of estimating
private residuals a couple of sides
about that we also did for sort of
looking for significance of of the model
parameters and the first author and that
Philippe will give a talk in the next
workshop in April about that but
basically the algorithm is pretty
straightforward essentially what you're
trying to do is density estimation right
so you want to take this no dense we
estimate the density some challenges
that appear is like you don't have any
bounds on this that you can get these
residuals in just estimating the density
of the residuals right and then any
adding or removing one remove one point
here so it's not it's not very sensitive
but of course the you don't have any
bounds on residuals so you need to sort
of estimate these tight bounds on this
otherwise your error it's just going to
sort of large but you can do it it's not
not too difficult and so this is sort of
the idea residual plots and this is what
the residual plots look under
differential privacy and actually we had
the social scientists we wrote a paper
about this in annals of applied
statistics we had this manual scientists
do their analysis on the real data and
then but before they'd also do it on the
synthetic data but then use these to
verify whether to do the verification
steps like did the model that they do a
trained on this area did it does it
actually make sense or not and they were
able to come to roughly the same kinds
of kinds of consensus right so yeah so
the open question is really here are and
it's a really a call to the substations
is like how do what a statistical test
that can still be in artifacts of data
whose article algorithm and what kinds
of error verification should we be doing
and how do you manage privacy budget for
for for verification okay I'm going to
finish in one slide and then I take your
question okay so I want to end again
with this checklist for deployment right
so sorry
think carefully about not just about how
do you design your algorithm for
differential privacy and in fact I
didn't talk about this today it's really
important talk about all of the other
other aspects as well right
understand your uses of the data because
that is very very important design
design your priority carefully and more
very very importantly understand how to
interpret error and communicated that
thank you get a question here yeah
doesn't come into the model domestic so
you are using the synthetic data to
generate a model right and now you are
asking is this this this model make any
sense really on the true data right so
in theory it is used to generate the
model because that's all you have access
to why would you do that that's a very
good point right so why would you do
this because when the Census Bureau
releases data they don't know who all
its users are right so they just release
a synthetic data set now you as a you as
a researcher has two options one option
is you can go through six months of
background checks and wait to run your
regression model on the true data set or
use the synthetic data set I'm saying is
there has to be a way to do that
Diagnostics because if you don't do it
then you maybe have making false
discoveries some route for me
that's what we want we think statistical
agency should do right if we are not
able to estimate the error in a data
independent fashion like one option is
if they're able to give sufficiently
good estimates of error and bias without
looking at the today Terr that's great
right in this case we were not able to
and so we had to add this additional
loop but of course it needs questions as
to how do you manage your budget with
the verification how do you do that
that's all good questions yes who is the
next question
sort of all the way from simple simply
adjusting your video coefficients from
the attenuation because there are all
the way to Bayesian methods to denoise
the data and so you know I just have one
point or not you have the best thing
about differential try to see and why
are looking at it's because this public
yes please tell us how to do this
Missy data I don't know what that
mechanism how I put in the noise and the
statisticians from know how to deal with
its tell us we don't know yeah so I
think you're and there are two issues
one is is the the reason your models bad
from the original data and is it an
artifact of the way you have generated
differentially private data and I think
as we've seen as a couple of these talks
it could actually be the latter because
yeah I'm good of them yeah it's
something like this you're basically
trading off privacy sending a sign
privacy budget to validate the bottles
set which means you're getting worse
data to begin with so you're more likely
to get something that fails to validate
what I'm not sure I'm not sure that I'm
not sure so okay so one thing that I
didn't talk about because I skipped over
a section is basically like there is a
fundamental orientation because second
which means that there are only certain
things that you can actually do well on
when you release datasets right so you
can specify that these are the only
things that you can hope to do well
right but then people will still want to
ask other questions so what do you tell
them you tell them if that question
doesn't match one of our questions it's
not going to do well sorry
right or you could say I can have some
ad hoc privacy budget for these other
questions right for some ad hoc
questions and so one way to allow that
is to sort of maybe have these sort of
verification kind of engines yes yes
Shafi
so you've done the regression on the
synthetic data yeah whether it makes
sense yeah whether it fits the real data
oh yeah whether assumptions make sense
or so on yes no no you don't do that you
basically you you you basically compute
a function between the two data set and
the model it's a function that takes as
input the to database and your model and
it outputs something the model C betas
here exactly yeah yes or no answer for
example yeah but that one bit of answer
could also leak some information so you
still have to give some amount of
privacy protection to that one bit of
answer because the analyst is the one
who's seeing that one bit of answer
which is more than what they have seen
from the synthetic data set if you spend
additionally there was no guarantee that
you do it anyway you just verify it's no
no no you didn't know it anyway if you
knew it anyway you wouldn't try it spend
extra budget to verify that it is
correct maybe the name verifying
verifying is not a good good name but
essentially what you're trying to see is
you are getting more information from
the from the database yes
what is that you really want to know
misfits is love and that in a true heart
analyst honest that's what they will
know when we think of the we think of
the analysts as an adversary
so anything that analyst can do you take
this offline maybe distinguish the
synthetic gate in the real is trying to
find something about some data subjected
in the rewrite so the security guarantee
we want to give is not about the entire
database it service not that we don't
want to leak anything of everything
about the entire database what you want
to protect is individual rows in the
database it's okay for the
distributional information to be learnt
write what you want to hide this
individual rows